Google is accused in a lawsuit of
tracking the movements of iPhone and
Android users even when privacy settings
have turned location history off and
supposedly don't allow this type of
tracking there is this feature called
location history on your phone you
aren't supposed to be physically tracked
by Google when you turn that off and
your location history places you visited
aren't supposed to be stored there's a
new lawsuit against Google which says
it's not true Google is tracking you
either way class-action lawsuit has been
filed on behalf of people who turned off
or at least believed that they had
turned off Google's location tracking
feature the lawsuit which is filed in
California claims that this violates
California law computer science
researchers at Princeton University got
involved and they confirmed that yes
indeed tracking was happening even when
location history had been turned off the
Help section of Google's website now
says that turning location history off
quote does not affect other location
services and that some location data may
be saved through other services like
search and maps is this shocking the
answer is obviously no what can we do
about it the answer is I don't know if
the lawsuit gets Google to change the
policy then okay that might be one step
forward but the truth is the way that
that is written there are many other
ways for Google to follow that by the
letter and not in spirit let me give you
an example if you turn location services
off and you are no longer tracked via
GPS even if you turn off GPS services
altogether on your phone the Wi-Fi you
connect to is easy to geolocate for
google and they would know where you are
based on the Wi-Fi networks that you're
connecting to IP scanning where you
restaurants and places that you look up
there are countless other ways even with
GPS services turned off never mind
location history turned off that goo
can track you so the question very
quickly becomes Pat are you switching to
MapQuest because of this I'm gonna have
to I mean I thought that when I turned
off my location history on Friday night
when I go to all the places I like to go
to that it was totally fine but
apparently not and even eggnog Nino
Moe's got not gonna help me but
seriously you're not actually so I'm not
changing you're not and I'm not either
and some people will say well if if you
don't take a stand then this isn't going
to get any better
I still think it doesn't really matter
because you can be tracked by IP address
not as precisely you can be tracked in a
bunch of other ways and even if the
class-action lawsuit is hugely
successful millions and millions of
people were impacted by this and every
single one of them is entitled to $15 if
they fill out complex class action
lawsuit forms and wait 18 months it's
still not going to make a huge
difference and most people aren't even
going to do it because the paperwork for
these things is extraordinarily onerous
so I I am concerned about this I am NOT
someone who says if I'm not concerned
about them knowing what I'm doing
I shouldn't be concerned about them
having more access than I want them to
have I don't fall for that I think that
is a slip I I resist slippery slopes
many times I think that actually is
opening the door to a slippery slope or
I just don't think we can do anything
about if you're not doing anything wrong
then you have nothing to worry about
about that one thing I am NOT someone
who subscribes to that and yet I don't
think this is nothing right and in even
I'll go even further even if Google
quote fixes this even though this is
clearly a feature and not a glitch and
this is extraordinarily valuable data
what if there you know the when you go
on your phone and you look at when
places are busiest that is partially
based on location history and a lot of
people find that to be extraordinarily
useful when you look at real-time
traffic on Google Maps that is partially
coming from location services and this
exact type of thing do you want to give
all of that up maybe the answer is yes
I'm
merely playing devil's advocate I think
it's just important when we think about
this this does not excuse for a second
what Google has done and if it's illegal
they should pay the price for it but a
lot of us would prefer the conveniences
that come with location services being
turned on that's just the reality yeah
I'm one of those people like I'm not
hypersensitive when it comes to my own
privacy and security and this type of
thing but I understand that some people
are and some people are worried about
giving Google all their information all
their data all the time yeah and for
those people they should have the right
to turn off those services I agree I
agree that that's absolutely something
they should be able to do as you could
probably tell I have way more sort of
questions in this story than answers and
that's kind of the reality of the entire
thing for some people this is super
binary I don't want Google tracking me
period other people don't care at all
which I as I mentioned have some
concerns with most people recognize the
value that comes from lots of location
related services and apps provided by
Google but we still want to feel like we
have some control over our data and how
we are being tracked and this lawsuit
makes us feel that if the allegations
are accurate that we don't have that
control I don't have the answers I don't
have the solution but I do want you to
tell me what you think